one of my favorite ways to close someone
is to just say whatever thing they said
they're struggling with that they're not
sure about you just say hey in a
hypothetical world where that didn't
exist would you say yes and whatever it
is if that thing doesn't exist and they
say sure then you literally now have
only one thing you need to solve to get
the sale right so if you're tired of
having people give you obstacle after
obstacle after obstacle you just say hey
if you had the time would you do it if
they say yes and it's like cool let's
figure out how to get you the time right
and then you can solve one problem and
make the deal the same thing is hey if
your wife were on board would you do it
okay cool then what would we need to do
to figure out so she wouldn't be worried
about it right so whatever the thing is
you just say hey in a hypothetic world
that didn't exist would you do it cool
and then you can close the one isolated
variable to get the deal done if you
like this video follow for more Tic Tacs
like this